I hate paperwork I hate it I hate it I
hate it I hate paperwork so much I hate
it can you tell that I hate paperwork I
hate it so much hey guys welcome to
another book update video I'm a little
upset today because i had to do
paperwork and in the context of this
being a book update video with the
publisher you have to sign an agreement
right that's an insanely long agreement
that you have to sign and it outlines
your relationship great and I signed it
and sent it off and then we had to make
a change where it's under my company
instead of under my personal name and
just for that is another four-page
agreement that design three copies of
and send it in and for the past three
weeks has been sitting on my desk and my
agents calling me and my literary agents
calling me insane Evan are you going to
sign the agreement we need to get it in
and you know this in advance with the
book a nice advance and I don't get that
advance and my agents don't get any
piece of that advance until I've
actually sent in all the paperwork and
I'm just I'm so frustrated that I have
to do this that taking the walk to the
end of street which is what I'm doing
right now today's the day were actually
sending it in just drives me nuts and
because I'm doing what I'm doing more
important things right like hey I'm
actually writing the book anyway today's
the day it happens and just as a general
rule I'm not a big fan of paperwork
people who've been on my team for years
have not have not had the sign
agreements somebody's waving have not
had the sign agreements with me we have
an understanding we have an
understanding of what a relationship is
going to be and it's worked for me and
and I get how some of you may think
that's crazy and you may think I've been
screwed over before I've had people rip
me off and I need to have everything
down in writing and I think that that
creates just a culture of mistrust and
it for me is kind of like having a
prenup agreement you know I haven't had
a prenup agreement in my marriage and I
don't know if you guys do in yours and
some people recommend it and I'm sure
what I'm saying don't do paperwork you
know all the lawyers who are watching
are freaking out right now I think if
you build the team where people trust
you and
you care about them and you have an
understanding together that's what you
need to get started and if you have some
light paperwork because that's what you
need to do then find that's cool but
like some people spend so much time just
creating paperwork that you don't allow
yourself to actually get work done right
that's why I bothers me because it gets
in a way of getting work done and so I'm
getting it done today but again you know
I've walked away from deals because
there was too much paperwork and if I
didn't care so much about this book and
giving it out and having something for
you guys that I think would really add a
lot of value then I might walk away from
it you know send this mail in no you
can't do it online no you can't sign it
has to be mailed in drives me nuts
anyway so thank you for listening to my
right I feel a little better now believe
nation coming to the rise thank you so
much so um yeah I want to know your
thoughts on paper work are leaves on the
comments below and we're gonna get to
your questions so last week I did this
from San Francisco on only a couple
hours sleep and I super appreciate you
guys being supportive and hanging in
there with me so a couple questions came
in first one is from ed ed rights in to
say looking forward to reading your book
I'll pre-order your book any day believe
thanks man really appreciate that
support next up jarhead have fun in
California at what point you get
assigned a manager so I quickly talked
about this wireless in San Francisco was
I got a YouTube manager and I was gonna
okay so while I was walking my iPad ran
out of space because I filmed all of
those videos for you guys in California
and so I'm going to finish up answering
your questions about the book jarhead
have fun in California man at what point
did you get assigned a manager so in in
my last book update I talked about going
to California partly because I gotta
sign the YouTube manager who was helping
me with my channel at what point I want
to say it happened three weeks ago I had
maybe eighty five thousand subscribers
maybe 90,000 subscribe now probably
eighty eighty to eighty-five thousand
subscribers yeah so again I'm lucky most
people don't get one until they're way
way way ahead of me Tamara weeks most in
with a channel I agree this earth
compliment coming from YouTube
congratulations thanks Tamara what does
it mean to
have a youtube channel manager
congratulations on that too that's a
great question and I'm not fully sure to
be honest it's really just having a
point of contact at youtube I think if
you know if I have a problem a question
something need help with then I have
somebody that I can reach out to
directly who can hopefully help me
through that process typically how they
work as a they set up a google hangout
with you and so I had a google hangout
with him and then he said I want to
schedule more time because it's such an
innovative channel I want to talk to you
more and he invited me the same Bruno
they're hurt office to go meet with him
so that's why I went down and she
finished with I would never have known
that you only have two hours sleep glad
we energize you it's really true I get
anxious when I don't get my videos up
for you guys and knowing that I'm
helping answer questions really it's the
best part of my week but best part of my
week zeno and be careful with that ring
you better not lose it it's true I do
play with my ring a lot we did have one
video where I jumped off of a runway and
and it fell off and then where's my ring
I got to find it but so far so good I
don't know it just helps me whenever I'm
thinking it just I like having a
distraction I don't know I guess doing
something with your hands for me let's
at least allows you to be more creative
Paul Chan this is something new I
learned using Google Hangouts record the
conversation and process instead of
writing everything less thanks and
please sleep more yeah thank you for the
sleep comment yeah I love using Google
Hangouts 12 to try to give information
for you guys so as I'm learning
hopefully you guys are learning that
process too but then also i use it
personally and a lot of private videos
as well that just so i can refer back to
them and have content there or from
showing how i do something and want to
share that with my team i'll do a screen
capture and put it on google hangouts
it's really an amazing way to kind of
record things in a video format in south
with regard to writing a nonfiction book
have you checked out Ryan holidays way
of writing which you learned from Robert
Greene watch Ryan's interview on inside
quest thanks for that I have not heard
of Ryan holiday or robert greene so i
will check those things out aquata see
aquata see you're in my neck of the
woods welcome to the bay area thanks i
am back home now but i had a blast it
was a record heat in LA and it was
insanely hot and we were sweating all
over the place but the
San Francisco was awesome nice cool
breeze and we had a really fun time I
got a question for you a few years back
I landed a book deal with a well-known
publisher that was very hot to publish
my book but when the contract arrived
the terms were barely one notch above
work-for-hire we went back and forth
over the contract for a few months
ultimately I walked away from the deal
because I was pouring out my extensive
knowledge and experience into the book
and getting very little for it I've been
a bit sour and publishers since then for
a while I toyed with self-publishing but
I understanding importance of having a
major publisher putting its muscle and
effort behind your product you have any
tips on working with a publisher and
negotiating the contract is beneficial
to both of you on them this is a great
question and I have a couple of thoughts
one for most books I don't think
publishers do a lot and turn to the
marketing muscle and so even from my
book a lot is going to depend on me
being out there marketing promoting it
selling it and I'm not relying too much
on the publisher to do that and so the
publisher really helps with I guess
getting into stores with the editing
with the whole book creation process but
they're not the greatest at marketing it
for you so I wouldn't look to a
publisher to help with that regardless
of you doing self-publishing that's on
your own or working with a big publisher
I'm terms of getting the deal the two
things that I found helpful or one
having an audience right a lot of
publishers now are reaching out to
people where they're just trying to
close any deal and they're expecting you
to pay a certain amount up front in
pre-orders and that's how their funding
the book process which I don't know
might be a little slimy but if you have
an audience then they're willing to pay
a premium for that right and so I have
an audience and I would encourage you to
now build up your own audience build up
your own community so that when you have
something that you can create there's
not inside will buy it from you and two
I found having an agent really helped me
where we lined up meetings with
publishers back to back to back to back
to back she had all the connections and
in two days we met with all the major
publishers and got a bidding war
happening basically where is one
interviewing them to see if there's a
fit to see the understanding what i'm
trying to do with the book to see if I
think I can work with them and then what
kind of terms would be negotiated and so
my agent took care of negotiating the
terms but also putting one publisher
up against another in a tight time frame
to get the deal sign kind of like a real
estate transaction you want a bunch of
people in a bidding war for your house
that's what my agent did for me on the
book and so prior to that I had some
contacts with publishers but I wouldn't
have been able to line up all those
meetings with exactly the right person
to get the price kind of going up and up
and up so I think working with an agent
will also really help you next Malik
everyone thank you so much for answering
my video resume question and for your
answering everyone else's questions
during such a busy sleep-deprived time
for you your answers and feedback have
been very helpful for me I love learning
from your answers to other people's
questions to for a YouTube channel
manager to sing you as one of the most
innovative channels he's ever seen as
mind-blowing and inspiring congrats i'm
humbled to be able to support you in my
small way as the BTA earth thanks man I
appreciate it I wrote two short kindle
books earlier this year and found the
process very difficult I think I'm still
trying to figure out a good process for
writing my questions for you this week
are one when you're traveling do you
edit your own Evans book videos and
upload them to YouTube yourself or do
you upload your raw footage to shared
folder and have your editor edit and
post them later I'm trying to get better
insight into your specific process for
this part of your work so when i first
started my channel i was doing
everything myself i was filming i was
editing it was publishing now even when
i'm home even when i'm in toronto all
I'm doing is is being the guy behind the
camera I'm sorry in front of the camera
behind the camera Jason's behind the
camera some of them i do myself the tgim
i do myself because it's on the spot and
there's no editing the the book ones
typically where I'm walking on the
street and I have my iPad open the
family ones would be me but everything
else most of the videos the ants press
to the top 10s the the luncheon urns I
am in front of the camera and usually
Jason films them and christina was my
editor will edit them I usually send the
files to Christina but your google drive
she downloads them she will name them
she will upload them to youtube she'll
put in the description and the tags and
all that stuff so at the end I'll do a
final check to make sure I like
everything but for the most part the
majority of my work is just being in
front of the camera when I go away I
don't bring Jason with me you know I
can't pack him in a suitcase so I do my
own filming right so most of them were
on my
ipad which is why I ran out of space and
I have to do this video with Jason today
sometimes I bring my camera with me i
have a canon video camera that I record
myself as I'm walking so some of those
videos we're done by me too but that's
what happens when I'm traveling I am now
the cameraman and also the guy in front
of the camera but I'll still take all
the videos into the Christina and she
will edit them and put them up so I
don't I'm thankful for that because
that's a crazy ton of work and and she's
way more skilled at it than I am number
two and writing this book do you feel
you've defined a process for efficiently
writing future non-fiction books are you
considering continually writing books
like say a book a year that's a good
question probably uh the publisher wants
me to the publisher wants a relationship
where it's an ongoing commitment where
there's multiple books coming out it's a
lot of work and I think I've defined a
process that works for me I think I got
that process actually pretty fairly
early on where I start kind of
high-level what's the main theme of the
book and how we're breaking down into
sections and how I'm breaking those
sections of the chapters and then how
does each chapter look in each page look
that I i define pretty early on pretty
much before even started writing and
we've stuck to that there hasn't been
really many changes having my team
helped me to with some of the research
and some of the quotes and doing some of
the interviews to me is also really
helped alleviate the stuff that I'm not
as passionate about so my my short
answer is probably but I'm hedging a
little bit let's see how the first one
does see if I I like it for me it's
really a challenge of opportunity right
there's so many opportunities I can work
on writing the book takes up an insane
amount of time and should I be doing
that or should I be hosting a TV show
should I be investing into businesses
should I be starting the incubator
should I be creating an entrepreneur
cafe should I be making Toronto the best
city in the world for entrepreneurs like
there's a lot of demands on my time from
a business point of view and I have to
decide where is where is it going to
have the biggest impact and number three
is the book turning out as good as you
hoped it would be I'm pretty happy with
it by next week I should have the the
rough draft finished and then I'm going
to be editing going through going
through going through its kind of
refined but so far so good I'm really
excited next up Dominic
Tina who asked hey Evan its it's awesome
how guys YouTube notice all the hard
work you creativity put in your true
inspiration I do have one question it's
not exactly about book but similar I
want to get people to sign up for my
free online video happiness course I
created where I can give them way more
value than just in YouTube I tried
facebook twitter youtube vids but still
have low attention and people are not
willing to sign up what would you
recommend to get more people in I think
the free course gives tremendous value
and I want to help them as much as
possible I think what you need to do is
kick up as much noise in your industry
as possible that's my business model is
basically kicking up as much noise in my
community which is the entrepreneur
community so for you be looking at you
know who's your target audience who are
the people who most need to be happy and
you could say everybody I guess but if
you look at who watches my videos
there's outliers but it's mostly people
who are like me it's mostly people who
are around my age who are kind of like
me they resonate with me the most and so
I would start with the people who are
kind of like you and try to target them
with a lot of amazing free content right
I'm putting out three YouTube videos a
day right so from there at the end I'll
have a newsletter subscription I'll have
a youtube subscription and I funnel a
lot of people through my newsletter and
then i invite people to join my webinars
and i invite people to join the twitter
chats i'm doing and the google hangouts
that i'm doing and when i had the book
all and by people to hopefully by the
book right you guys want to buy the book
and i think that's really it i think
people underestimate how much work goes
into building a relationship right and
responding the comments and feedback and
being active and being engaged I think
you got it you got to add more value you
got to make the videos and the what your
tweets and your Facebook stuff better I
think with Facebook content is getting
harder the rank on its own organically
you have to do a lot more targeted
advertising with dark posts Twitter it's
more reaching out to people and in being
a part of their community and responded
their tweets and YouTube with more
putting out quality content right like
maybe your content isn't good enough yet
and that's kind of a harsh honest truth
like you look at my videos at the start
they they were ok but they just weren't
good enough and as I practice more I got
better as it did more videos I got
better and you will too so you have to
make more consistent content improve the
quality
the of it and then have a strong call to
action to join your newsletter give them
something free that they can get from
your newsletter and in there then you
can upsell your your course on happiness
last question from ali i need to find
that autobiographer to help me write a
book who should i contact that's a tough
one that's a very personal relationship
right that's one somebody that you're
now sharing really detailed information
about yourself to if you want to be good
on autobiography it's gotta dig deep
into you and not just be a surface level
stuff for people won't be interested to
its somebody that like you got to work
with them a long time right it's you're
going to meet with them a lot you're
gonna you're gonna ask me somebody
you're feeling comfortable with even
like thinking about how I got Jason help
me with the videos I I demoed and try it
out to other videographers before him
just to see cuz I'm gonna be with you
every week I need somebody who is on my
vibe who you know gives me energy to who
understands what i'm trying to do who
believes in the mission in the first two
people we're okay you know the technical
skills were okay I feel like it's
raining it's raining a little bit but
it's got to be somebody that you can
work with for an extended period of time
because writing an autobiography is no
joke and then someone who has the skills
right somebody who can actually write
somebody who can the hardest thing that
I found and working with writers is
somebody who can match my voice right
training somebody who can match your
voice the way you would say things is
tough now in terms of finding that
person it's not it's not just you know
putting up an ad and saying hey do you
want to write my autobiography I would
look at one people that you already know
i would start spreading the message to
your network you to your friends and say
you're looking for this because there
may be somebody in your circle who could
do it or just by letting them know they
may know somebody right like friends of
friends who might be able to be a good
contact for you and 2 i'd be looking at
books look at other autobiographies look
at other books that have been written
with somebody and see which books you
like like which autobiographies do you
love to read that we're either ghost
written or written with somebody and
find out who that person is and contact
them and what i try to do is set up a
mini-trial where you're you're working
with them on one small part
the book and see who who gets it like
who do you riff with who is asking the
right question who's giving you the
right energy do a bunch of mini trials
because somebody could look great on
paper but until you actually start
working with them you don't really have
a sense of if they're going to be a good
fit for you or not so that's a lot of
questions thank you guys so much if you
have more questions about my book the
book writing process leave it in the
comments below and I will answer it next
week thank you guys so much for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon